la dernière évasion d'albert spaggiari
le cerveau du plus célèbre doc de france
le casque de la société générale de nice
en 1976 le corps d'albert spaggiari mort
d'un cancer a été déposée ce matin
devant le domicile de sa mère chine le
grand bond en arrière arrestation
épuration commencer le vocabulaire
classique a repris ses droits le
gouvernement et la télévision chinoise
dénonce les contre révolutionnaires
tennis le tournoi de toutes les
surprises jusqu'en finale chez les dames
la numéro un mondiale steffi graf battu
en trois sets par l'espagnol sanchez
madame monsieur bonsoir
la presse a parfois à l'éloge un peu
trop flatteuse pour les malfaiteurs de
haut vol ce fut le cas pour albert
spaggiari dit le cerveau organisateurs
du plus célèbre cas de l'histoire du
gangstérisme français de l'après-guerre
celui de la société générale de nice en
1976 arrêté un an plus tard évadé de
manière spectaculaire albert spaggiari
était en cavale depuis 12 ans elle s'est
terminée ce matin devant le domicile de
sa mère à hyères dans le var
deux inconnus ont déposé son corps
devant sa porte
albert spaggiari 56 ans atteint d'un
cancer du poumon voulait rentrer en
france pour y mourir
c'est en juillet 1976 que ce photographe
niçois encore inconnue à l'époque allait
soudainement se rendre célèbres en
attaquant la succursale de la société
générale à la tête d'un véritable
commando en passant par les égouts bruno
gex voici l'homme aux multiples visages
albert spaggiari après douze années de
mascarade le cerveau du casse de nice a
terminé sa cavale ici au quartier
paradis ailleurs deux inconnus masqués
auraient déposé son corps cette nuit au
domicile de sa mère qui selon son avocat
savait son fils atteint d'un cancer du
poumon
elle avait eu de ses nouvelles oui bien
sûr là vous savez un fils et sa mère ça
correspond toujours c'est bien évident
elle savait qu'ils étaient donc
malade il avait une envie furieuse qui
pourra servir à tous ceux qui envisagent
en un jour d'aller en cavale c'est de
revenir au pays
la descente de spaggiari dans les égouts
de nice c'est l'image que l'on retiendra
de ce casse de la société générale l'un
des plus audacieux
c'était en juillet 1976 spaggiari et sa
bande d'égoutiers parviennent à dérober
plus de 46 millions de francs un travail
d'expert pour s'introduire dans les
coffres le gant creusé un tunnel de huit
mètres de long jusqu'à la banque après
avoir perforé le mur de la chambre forte
les gangsters fracture 337 coffre deux
jours d'un travail méticuleux signé de
la main même de spaggiari sans haine
sans armes sans violence spaggiari et
arrêté trois mois plus tard par le
directeur de la pj de l'époque honoré
gévaudan pour ce dernier
c'était un aventurier hors du commun et
non un homme du milieu 10 mars 77 pas
jerry se fait la belle il saute de la
fenêtre du cabinet du juge d'instruction
et rebondit 7 mètres plus bas sur le
toit de cette voiture
les rumeurs les plus folles ont couru
sur la personnalité de cet ancien de
l'oas militants d'extrême droite agent
au service de la cia
on cherche encore son vrai visage mais
derrière cet arsène lupin il ya sans
doute un homme qui voulait à tout prix
faire parler de lui
l'enquète que vous allez suivre
maintenant à quinze jours d'avancé sur
l'actualité de l'été à partir du 1er
juillet sur toutes les côtes françaises
les plaisanciers vont ressortir leur
embarcation et chaque année
malheureusement des accidents dus à
l'imprudence ou à l'insouciance se
répète
récemment encore rappelez vous la faire
de ce hors-bord conduit dit-on par le
frère du président syrien hafez el-assad
qui avait tué un baigneur sur la côte
d'azur
un autre exemple choisi ce soir une
petite fille de 11 ans grièvement
blessée au large d'une plage espagnole
depuis et bien ses parents font tout
pour obtenir une indemnisation mais le
droit maritime qui s'applique à ce type
d'accidents réserve bien des mauvaises
surprises en quête de thierry calmette
et pierre laurent constants
johnson c'est benji diane aujourd'hui 14
ans son compagnon à trois ans et demi un
cadeau de ses parents juste après
l'accident le bras droit amputer le
visage défiguré diane lutte pour
retrouver une vie normale
vous ne la verrez pas de face mais elle
veut témoigner quand même en outre 86 en
espagne à quelques mètres de la plage
diane aide à l'amarrage d'un canot
pneumatique le pilote seul occupant à
bord tombe à la mer il n'a pas branché
de brasse les coupe-circuits sur le
moteur hors bord le bateau fou tournoi
et l'hélice h le corps de la fillette
depuis infirme traumatisée elle se
réadapte difficilement j'essaie d'être
parce que ça me gêne parce que j'ai peur
qu'il le répète à tout le monde et puis
apprend le me regardent bizarrement
c'est dur j'ai des petits problèmes
qu'elle est qu'elle était plus difficile
pour tous et adapté mais c'était de
réécrire de berlin gauche qu'il
connaissait le pilote du bateau quitte
accidenté et il n'a jamais revu depuis
6 il nous regarde qu'est ce que tu as à
lui dire mais je sais qu'ils prennent de
mes nouvelles et que qui devrait mettre
son doigt cette sécurité à chaque fois
qu'ils en mer ne pas se fier aux
apparences la douceur de sa voix
dissimule le désarroi et la colère de
toute la famille sens accru par un
jugement prononcé voici trois semaines
le plaisancier fautif un ami la famille
voit sa responsabilité limitée par la
loi et celle de son assurance aussi
moins de 500 mille francs d'indemnités
pour une vie brisée
pourquoi la navigation de plaisance se
trouvaient six mille et au droit
maritime international loi du 3 janvier
67 et suivantes
même régime pour un canot pneumatique et
un superpétrolier loi compliqué qui
aboutit à limiter la responsabilité du
fautif on se pose plein de questions 1
par exemple comment se fait-il qu'un
chauffard de la mère ait le droit de
limiter sa responsabilité alors
qu'ottawa terrestre ça n'existe pas a
pas totalement irresponsables
responsables et ils payent pleinement ou
alors comment se fait-il qu'un zodiac
est considéré comme un navire comment se
fait-il que 15 et diac n'a pas le droit
d'avoir un équipage en nombre
suffisant et en qualité ça hérisse ans
comment se fait-il que cette loi de la
plaisance soit rattachée à une loi
maritime international désormais robert
sens à une obsession faire changer ses
lois pour que la navigation de plaisance
est un régime légal comparable par
exemple à celui des accidents de la
route
pour punir les chauffards de la mer
comme celui qui nous regardent revoit
dionne pour la première fois depuis 86
yens qui elle prend ses responsabilités
et qui un jour nous fera face répression
c'est le titre de l'actualité à
l'étranger ce samedi en chine tout
d'abord le temps de la normalisation est
venu un mot trompeur lorsqu'il
s'applique à certains pays en
l'occurrence retour à la normale
signifie sur place épuration
arrestations des responsables des
manifestations des semaine dernière en
paraphrasant dans le sait tous on peut
parler aujourd'hui d'un grand bond en
arrière
le col mao a fait sa réapparition
remplaçant la cravate pour les
dirigeants chinois et les images qui
nous parviennent désormais de chine nous
rappelle des périodes que l'on croyait à
tort révolue
jérôme benest pour la première fois
depuis un mois et demi le drapeau
chinois flotte à nouveau sur une place
tiananmen des verts symboles abondamment
diffusée à la télévision chinoise
ce qui reste du pouvoir traumatisés dans
le raz-de-marée pour la démocratie
actionne tous les leviers de la reprise
en u désinformation et la propagande
officielle présente sans relâche à la
télévision une population réconcilier
avec l'armée même avec les chars qu'ils
ont écrasé les militaires n'ont pas tiré
sur le peuple affirme même les
commentateurs officiels répression des
centaines d'ouvriers et d'étudiants
rescapés des massacres sont aujourd'hui
entre les mains de la police secrète
qualifié de fauteurs de trouble ou
bandits contre révolutionnaires ils sont
désignés comme les seuls responsables
des événements pékin nettoyer des
dernières traces de la révolte vit
aujourd'hui dans une atmosphère de peur
et de délation le travail des
journalistes est de plus en plus
difficilement à l'université entouré par
cinq mille soldats la liberté
d'expression du printemps chinois est
aujourd'hui étouffer une patrouille
arrive explique cet étudiant il faut
partir vite
une patrouille arrive les leaders du
mouvement étudiant ont aujourd'hui
disparu
cachez arrêtés ou même tuer nul ne sait
disparue la jeune caroline commandant en
chef de tiananmen disparu du rkc le
playboy contesté et wang dan qui selon
la rumeur de hong kong aurait été tué
dans les combats
pourtant le retour à la normale n'est
qu'apparent en dents-de-scie au ping n'a
pas encore vaincu une contestation aviv
et au contraire par la soif de vengeance
il on reste perplexe sur notre
solidarité à l'égard des manifestants
chinois lorsqu'on constate comme cet
après midi à paris qu'une manifestation
de soutien a réuni quant à environ 350
personnes qui symboliquement déposé un
crêpe noir au pied de la colonne de la
bastille avant des défilés jusqu'au
trocadéro répression encore en union
soviétique cette fois ci dans la
république d'ouzbékistan au départ il y
a plus d'une semaine maintenant des
affrontements interethniques entre la
population majoritaire et une minorité
d'origine turque déporté dans cette
république sous le gouvernement de
staline des affrontements qui se sont
transformés en contestation du régime
soviétique conséquences et bien
intervention de troupes et de policiers
envoyés par moscou
christophe martet nous commandent
maintenant les premières images qui nous
sont parvenus cet après midi
d'ouzbékistan des voitures calcinées des
centaines de maisons brûlées
ces images témoignent de la violence des
affrontements en ouzbékistan des
affrontements qui depuis plus de 10
jours auraient fait au moins 80 morts et
près d'un millier de blessés
7000 hommes tentent d'imposer depuis
dimanche le couvre-feu dans cette région
où les émeutes oppose deux communautés
les ouzbeks et les mechs traite ces
derniers d'origine turque avait été
déporté de géorgie par staline pendant
la deuxième guerre mondiale et 15 mille
membres de cette communauté vivant
aujourd'hui en ouzbékistan hier selon la
presse soviétique les bandes de jeunes
ouzbeks s'en serait pris aux bâtiment
officiels auraient bloqué des trains est
pris d engins de pompiers
les émeutiers seraient équipés d'armes à
feu et de cocktails molotov cette
semaine près de 11000 mais chouette ont
été évacués pour être regroupés dans des
camps sous la protection des forces de
l'ordre
dans le même temps à moscou suite des
changements et même des habitudes à la
tête du pays le premier ministre
monsieur riche kof a présenté son
nouveau gouvernement cet après-midi le
nombre des ministères et des comités
d'état et ramené deux cents à 57
la moyenne d'âge des ministres s'en
ressent donc 55 ans de moyenne ce qui
est tout à fait nouveau en union
soviétique
en france les bons citoyens que nous
sommes constate je dirais avec
étonnement que les chèques qu'ils ont
envoyé pour payer leur tiers
provisionnel n'ont pas été encaissé par
l'état la raison elle est simple le
personnel les impôts est en grève pour
des questions de salaires mais il
revendique également des moyens
supplémentaires pour accomplir leur
tâche c'est à dire limiter la fraude
fiscale en quête de jean-pierre métivet
et philippe menut vous l'avez sans doute
remarqué sur votre compte en banque
l'échec du tiers provisionnel ne sont
pas tous des beats et les agents du fisc
ne les transmettre plus à la banque de
france la raison la grande misère du
service des impôts
regardez il ya bien un peu
d'informatique mais l'essentiel du
travail se fait toujours à la main le
règne de la paperasse au détriment des
contrôles bien souvent par exemple pour
les impôts locaux voient les
propriétaires bon on arrive à les
retrouver mais si tous les locataires
qu'on avait pas trouvés suffit qu'on
change reste où les tous les ans à
l'hôtel communal et ça lui avait disparu
de la circulation
dans ce cas la ville paiera pour les
introuvables
à paris toujours un inspecteur peut
avoir plus de 1000 entreprises à
vérifier en province c'est bien moins
mais problème on rembourse très mal les
frais kilométriques des contrôleurs
de fait les agents préfère à choisir des
vérifications un petit peu moins loin
pour essayer de rentrer dans leurs frais
donc et de ne pas y viennent de leur
poche en fait en travaillant pour
l'administration
le résultat c'est l'inspecteur général
des impôts lui même qu'il indique
l'apparition de petits paradis fiscaux
de fait dans des endroits peu contrôlées
suprême arguments des syndicats afin de
justifier leurs actions le poids de la
fraude fiscale il estime à 160 milliards
de francs par an au total sur laquelle
l'état ne récupère que 25 milliards 160
milliards c'est c'est pas de la piquette
c'est quand même plus de 10% du budget
de l'état donc que les français se
rendent compte qu'il y avait nécessité
de lutter contre cette fraude
je crois que c'est une des premières
missions qu'on a nous que devrait avoir
le ministère des finances
bref une grève pour les grands principes
pour l'égalité des français devant
l'impôt mais tout de même les agents du
fisc n'oublie pas de demander des
augmentations de salaires
l'assemblée nationale a voté la nuit
dernière en première lecture la loi
d'orientation de l'éducation nationale
présentée par son ministre monsieur
lionel jospin sol est les socialistes
ont voté pour les communistes se sont
abstenu et l'opposition a voté contre
paradoxe que cette loi votée sans éclats
de voix alors que le projet avait
souvenons nous a accouché dans la
douleur et les grèves de l'hiver dernier
chantal qui merde
ce n'est pas une grande révolution pas
même une réforme mais la loi je spa
marque cependant des changements
significatifs pour le système éducatif
les enseignants futurs instituteurs et
professeurs seront désormais tous
recrutés au même niveau
la licence est formé ensuite dans des
nouveaux instituts universitaires de
formation des maîtres
ouverture de ces instituts dans un an
plus deux trimestres
on travaillera cette semaine pour deux
semaines de repos l'année scolaire
devrait se terminer environ mi juillet
pour reprendre environ mi septembre la
scolarité des élèves est désormais
divisé en cycle si peu de trois ans en
primaire et de deux ans en secondaire
pas de redoublement à l'intérieur d'un
cycle pour les diplômes de
l'enseignement technique et
professionnel
les jeunes feront des stages
obligatoires dans les entreprises
françaises ou étrangères
les parents d'élèves délégués aux
conseils départementaux académique et
nationaux pourront bénéficier d'une
autorisation d'absence des entreprises
et seront indemnisés
c'est un pas vers un véritable statut de
parents d'élèves
en revanche en cas de litige sur
l'orientation
dan élèves c'est le chef d'établissement
qui tranchera et non les parents comme
le proposait la droite
autre amendement malchanceux celui des
centristes qui se sont vu refuser leur
proposition d'aménager un temps libre
pour les activités extrascolaires ou
religieuse la sphère touvier l'un des
chefs de la milice lyonnaise arrêté
après 45 ans de cavale protégé par
certaines filières religieuse le
cardinal de lyon monseigneur de courtrai
annonce que toutes les archives de
l'église vont être mises à la
disposition de la justice
quelles qu'en soient les conséquences
rémy règle j'ai bien précisé que je
cherchais seraient ouverts que ce qui va
pas dire à tous vents souhaitait des
historiens qualifié plusieurs déjà
prêtes à leur cou nous verrons ce que je
n'ai pas dit mais qui apparaissait comme
une évidence et qui est ouvert aux juges
l'une des raisons pour lesquelles je
souhaite la transparence et la vérité
c'est pour éviter les mensonges rampant
je préfère que les taux soient
clairement établies par ce que l'on peut
savoir de commandes à se repentir à qui
demander pardon plutôt que ni le sang
suspectes ont dit le tas de choses qui
ne tiennent pas debout j'en suis sûre il
a d'autres qui sont vrais nous la
regrettons
j'ai persuadé que l'église beaucoup
moins éclaboussé beaucoup moins dans la
vérité que par les rumeurs bon confesse
et les rites la question du droit
d'asile est une question elle est
respectable il faut voir mais il ya
aussi la question de protection vaut la
peine de savoir pourquoi certaines
protections se sont se sont fait tilt et
voit la peine de savoir pourquoi c'est
la question des filières de protection
je ne connais pas très bien je bougeais
découvert je découpe beaucoup chaud
depuis 15 jours puis il y a eu cet
accueil par monseigneur charles du caire
cet accueil qui est un accueil de bonté
mais qui a tout de même manqué de
depuis le lancement des listes dans ce
domaine là est en tout cas qui a jeté un
soupçon en grande partie du mérite et
soustraire la justice comme on vient de
le rappeler ceci n'est pas admis tandis
que protéger un prof cris oui c'est
traditionnel bien entendu mais y'avait
l'équivoque entre le droit d'asile
les protections et les filières de
protection cette équivoque doit être
longue quant à mon point de vue
au tour maintenant à nos problèmes
quotidiens parmi la multitude des
corporations une qui regroupe pourtant
huit cent mille personnes en france se
manifestent finalement très très peu il
s'agit des secrétaires toutefois cette
année leur métier s'affirme comme une
profession à part entière puisqu'elle
viennent d'organiser leur premier salon
professionnel à paris
reportage de marc maisonneuve et
philippe baron secrétaire un métier
d'homme
c'était avant 1850 avec les premières
machines à écrire le sexe de la
profession change totalement ou presque
aujourd'hui 98 % des secrétaires sont
des femmes elles sont huit cent mille à
être en activité en france
après le téléphone le traitement de
texte l'évolution technologique
commandes disposant parfois des
individus alexandre dumas déclaré même
en 1850 qu'une fameux perdu toute sa
féminité en mettant les pieds dans les
bureaux puis la machine à écrire est
venu le téléphone avec la fin du siècle
le métier c'est mécanisée un métier qui
ce mécanisme se dévalorise et c'est
l'entrée massive des femmes dans la
profession et comprennent qu'ils rendent
heures et dépendances pour une évolution
de carrière singulièrement limité car
elle est soumise au pouvoir d'un seul
cette action est amené le patron est un
homme de la scène
un dossier bien fait ces dossiers du
patro un dossier mal fait ces deux
dossiers de la secrétaire un métier plus
difficile qu'il y paraît une part de
responsabilité étroite
un emploi du temps répétitif commenter
sa part m
voir le planning de la journée le tri du
courrier la réponse provient
et après tout de suite on attaque les
choses un petit peu sérieuse
le problème à régler
téléphone
la façon d'exercer cette profession est
largement aussi différentes que la
manière d'y arriver
se retrouver à chercher un emploi
allez dans société ça se fait déjà
différence de technologie différence de
salaire de 6000 à 20 mille francs
mais un rôle-clé la secrétaire est à
l'origine de l'idée que l'on se fait de
l'entreprise les élections européennes
maintenant la campagne s'accélère à une
semaine du vote au zénith à paris cet
après midi monsieur giscard d'estaing
succède à philippe herzog qui occupaient
la scène encore hier soir discours
européen mais aussi préoccupations
internationales la réunion a commencé
par la présentation d'une délégation
d'étudiants chinois un reportage de
laurent boussier et roger ma chère amie
française
tu avais tant que romain à un peuple qui
a tenu longtemps envie de vous rejoindre
autant la grande famille mondiale que
démocratie et de liberté appelle d'un
membre de la délégation des étudiants
chinois pour la démocratie présence de
chanteurs polonais proche de solidarité
dom sommes encore du meeting de l'union
au zénith la chine
la pologne avec l'environnement les
droits de l'homme la solidarité le sida
tous ces thèmes porteurs auprès des
jeunes militants udf et rpr ont été
abordés par les membres de la liste de
valéry giscard d'estaing l'ancien
président de la république qui portait à
la boutonnière un ruban blanc signe de
deuil en chine a parlé de l'europe mais
aussi de l'union udf rpr
pour moi le signe de l'union
le vrai signe c'est quand ceux qui ont
envie de crier vive jusqu'à krivine
chirac
on en est très habile chirac rebibes
jusqu'à seulement ultime parisien de la
liste d'union le zénith aura permis aux
colistiers de valérie giscard d'estaing
de définir une fois de plus leur but
pour eux il faut changer la politique
socialiste en battant la liste de
laurent fabius
c'est pas si ça va vraiment simplifié
les choses les discours des hommes
politiques ne sont pas forcément
exactement le reflet de l'europe sur le
terrain du moins en effet la communauté
connaître encore des situations bien
différentes
exemple au portugal dernier pays à
entrer dans la communauté
qu'y at il de commun entre nos pays
industrialisés et ce groupe d'hommes et
de femmes installées à 60 km à peine de
lisbonne sur les bords du tage
différence de niveau de vie ou plutôt de
vie tout simplement
reportage de valérie fournier et jean
corneille la légende veut qu'il descende
des vikings tout simplement parce qu'au
xviiie siècle leurs ancêtres sont
arrivés en bateau conquérir les rives du
tage surprenant à l'époque pour les
habitants de villafranca de cheer à
devoir débarquer des marins sur les
berges de leur fleuve eu des
propriétaires terriens qui s'intéressent
plus à la corrida canne à pêche
la pêche n'a rien donné à risques la
dure depuis au moins trois jurys
pourtant on est nombreux
on s'éparpille sur le tage mais moi
comme je suis vieux je reste là près des
berges
c'était plus pour moi en fait ils
viennent du nord du portugal
là où la misère est plus forte erreur de
parcours d'appréciation ils pensaient qu
ici la seule était plus abondante mais
cela ne rapporte rien regarder les
abeilles et russe c'est cela rien
je t'ai nous est king moi et mon mari on
a un petit bateau une petite maison où
avait germé lionel et on boit on ne peut
pas faire mieux c'est comme cela que mes
cinq enfants je les ai élevés dans cette
barre tous les sens et auxerre affronte
marché une fille qui est née ici même
oui dans le bateau c'est la plus jeune
autrefois nous avions une cabane en tôle
et en plastique là dans le bateau pour
nous protéger c'était notre maison en
rangée on vivait comme ça il n'a pas la
vie n'est vraiment pas facile j'ai la
santé va tout va bien
l'entrée de son pays dans les
communautés européennes ne modifie en
rien la vie de maria elle n'imagine même
pas ce que cela peut représenter
depuis deux siècles les avis rouge
vivent en parfaite autarcie
pourtant l'argent est entré dans leurs
villages ils ne conçoivent comme un
moyen des changes
un troc manuel le chef avec sa femme
rosa ils reviennent de la pêche
aujourd'hui satisfait la tête kg des
fois la pêche est meilleur aujourd'hui
ça doit rapporter un petit quelque chose
aux avants marché unique moment où elle
sort de son village pour vendre le
produit de sa pêche là après grillage
banni les aviez roches attendent
toujours l'autorisation de construire
leur maison
notre force c'est que quand ils
détruisaient nos maisons nous la nuit on
les reconstruisent air sans notre
volonté nous n'existerions plus mais là
vers aux usures fort et nous avons
réussi
je préfère vivre ici c'est ici que je
suis né dans l'eau est comme le poisson
j'aime l'air pur du tage quand je me
lève le matin la première chose que je
fais c'est de venir voir le tage pour
savoir s'il va bien
c'est la première chose que je fais voir
le tage
les avis roches résiste encore ils
savent que la disparition de leur site
et les entraînerait dans les bidonvilles
de la périphérie de lisbonne ou portes
de la civilisation de la communauté
européenne
le sport c'est presque la victoire pour
le français laurent fignon dans le tour
d'italie dans l'avant dernière étape
gagnée par l'italien bugno malgré une
chute sans gravité bien laurent fignon
reprend même quelques secondes à ses
principaux adversaires qu'il devance de
plus d'une minute trente laurent fignon
peut donc voir la vie en rose ou presque
avant la dernière étape de demain contre
lamont le tennis maintenant roland
garros le tournoi de toutes les
surprises en 1989 même en finale des
dames la logique n'a pas été respecté
cet après-midi la numéro un mondiale
steffi graf battu en trois sets par
l'espagnol sanchez roland garros ne
rejoigne ont tout de suite jean mamère
genre oui je vous entends daniel je
dirais 40 76 et bien là réalisé un
triple événement aujourd'hui
d'abord elle a fait sauter la caisse des
bookmakers personne n'avait parié sur
elle ou presque ensuite elle est la plus
jeune vainqueur de ce tournoi féminin
et puis arantxa sanchez aujourd'hui est
devenu un héros national est la première
espagnole à remporter le tournoi de
roland garros elle peut l'embrasser très
fort cette coupe que peu de monde
s'attendait à la voir tenir elle seule
y croyez aujourd'hui j'étais très motivé
surtout depuis que chang avait battu le
numéro un je me disais moi aussi je dois
pouvoir y arriver alors je me suis bien
accroché plus en plus j'ai vraiment j'ai
vraiment bien joué un grand match
en revanche steffi graf aujourd'hui un
mal joué même si elle a pris un set
elle ne fut que l'ombre d'elle-même
surtout lorsqu après trois heures de jeu
elle sert pour le gain du match
arantxa sanchez
en fait tu appliques la tactique de
steffi graf le rouleau compresseur
elle s'est battue sur toutes les balles
a tout ramené et même au pire moment n'a
jamais perdu sa confiance
graf elle apparemment n'a jamais eu
confiance
la preuve une seule balle de match a été
nécessaire arantxa sanchez une nouvelle
faute de steffi graf sans doute très
épuisés arantxa sanchez s'écroule sous
un immense bonheur
mais quelle fair-play aussi de la part
de steffi graf avec en final cette
petite accolade même vaincu on conserve
tout de même dans le tennis féminin
une certaine dignité cet après midi jean
surprise peut être demain alors
maintenant avec chang contre hedberg
écossais a lui aussi favori et oui on ne
sait plus on ne sait plus sur qui parier
alors demain ça serait aussi encore le
plus jeune vainqueur parce que michael
chang est le plus jeune finaliste de
roland garros il fait encore mieux que
que mats wilander
alors la surprise c'est lui la plus
totale de ce tournoi toute façon c'est
la révélation
mais je pense que michael jones et
surtout la grande énigme
alors on lem il divise il ya on le
haïssait aussi mais surtout il a une
grande personnalité qui est très très
difficile à cerner
qui se cache derrière ce masque
imperturbable de concentration un garçon
de 17 ans qui cherche vers sa mère en
secours psychologiques
à défaut d'être parfois physiques ou un
garçon qui cherche vers le ciel la
solution à ces problèmes le plus souvent
les plus immédiats j'espérais bien que
dieu que jésus-christ soit avec moi et
me ferait sortir de ce match
ou bien est-ce le plus grand bluffeur du
tennis moderne qui se permet de servir à
la cuillère face au numéro un mondial
ivan lendl et surtout de réussir le tour
de force de le déstabiliser
un récidiviste qui pour perturber
l'adversaire montrent même sur une
deuxième balle de service
mais chang en fait c'est peut-être tout
simplement un énorme gagneur au mental
très solide qui se bat sur chaque point
avec une énergie totale reste à savoir
qui demain face à stefan edberg va mener
la danse
rameau simplement peut-être pour être
tout à fait complète de la finale du
double messieurs il ya un français dans
la sphère celles qui sont en finale de
roland garros alors nous allons
peut-être aller vite sur le central une
petite seconde pour dire qu' il y a deux
sets à un en faveur de la paire
américaine crade mcenroe et que prône un
centre à mcenroe mène 6 jeux à 5
mais que le service et aux français
winogradsky est au service ici vous le
découvrez en direct donc possibilité
d'égaliser à 6 partout
un match qui s'éternise qui s'éternise
les deux équipes sont assez proches
l'une de l'autre
merci jean pour ce rapport complet sur
les événements de cet après midi à
roland garros autre événement ce soir
sur antenne 2 à partir de 23h15 dans
l'une et noir lunettes noires spéciale
pour nuits de toutes les couleurs le
concert organisé par sos racisme pour
fêter son cinquième anniversaire sur
fond de bicentenaire de la révolution et
des droits de l'homme sur l'esplanade du
château de vincennes
thierry calme est au milieu non pas des
manifestants mais des participants à
cette fête beaucoup de monde et beaucoup
de bruit beaucoup de décibels au pied du
château de vincennes où les
organisateurs attendent plus de cent
mille personnes
cette cinquième fête des faits
pacy est dédié à toussaint louverture
esclave qui se révolte tarn haïti voici
deux siècles pour lutter contre
l'exploitation de l'homme par l'homme
c'est-à-dire contre l' esclavage au
cours du super concert de tout à l'heure
on pourra entendre jacques higelin
bernard lavilliers gold fait là en tout
une trentaine de groupes venus de tous
les coins du monde mais la fête a
commencé dès cet après midi au milieu du
village des potes nous avons assisté un
splendide carnaval d'époque les stands
de plus de 80 comités de sos racisme
venus de toute la france pour les
affaires d'or on voit des mains partout
mais attention la fête n'oublie surtout
pas les étudiants chinois morts place
tiananmen à pékin
ces jours derniers ce super concert leur
est aussi dédié
tout à l'heure harlem désir et le
ministre la culture inspecté une
dernière fois les troupes de l'égalité
comme il les appelle sur le podium géant
la fête pouvait commencer
elle durera jusqu'à très tard dans la
nuit en direct sur antenne 2 voilà
rendez vous est pris donc pour terminer
maintenant les rapports du tiercé qui se
courait cet après midi voici ils vont
s'inscrire sur votre écran le 8 le 6 et
le 12 ça rapporte un peu plus de 6000
francs et puis pour le quarté vous
ajoutez l'asse savoure apporte un peu
plus de cinquante deux mille francs
voilà ce journal est terminée tout de
suite après les prévisions météo de josé
blanc lapierre malgré tout malgré la
grève de la météo
ensuite bien entendu les dernières
informations aux alentours de 23 heures
avec figaro quant à moi je vous souhaite
d'abord une excellente soirée sur notre
chaîne et je vous dis à demain 13h pour
soir
à